pants get the rip on somebody besides
Warner Brothers in DC so in case you
haven't heard yet a couple of things
happened in pretty rapid succession
first Warner Brothers push back Aquaman
a few months I have no opinion on that
one way or the other there was no word
as to why they did it it's just
something they did that's fine
almost immediately Sony announced that
the venom movie that we kind of all
assumed either was going to happen or
was now way on the back burner is now
confirmed for the release date the
October of 2018 release dates that
Aquaman abandoned now this is surprising
for a few reasons because like I said I
think a lot of us had assumed that if
the project was not outright canceled it
wasn't going to be for a while because
we haven't gotten spider-man homecoming
yet and the vulture is set with that
that's not to say they couldn't see
venom but there's been no indication of
that and this seems to be kind of tight
it basically got 17 months to write it
get all the crew and cast lined up shoot
it edit it everything that if you're
talking big-budget superhero related
that is a tight turnaround now Paris is
already a screenwriter on it it's the
same screenwriter as alien covenant
which means I don't really have a basis
to know if he's any good or not now
apparently Alex Kurtzman who has been
attached to this project since you know
before they decide to completely Bay on
the amazing spider-man universe he still
attached to direct whether or not that's
a good thing it's hard to say I think
we'll have a better picture of that when
his mummy movie comes out later this
year but overall this just seems to be
snowballing really fast which is
concerning to me and actually it should
not be that big of a shot because I
don't know people remember this very
well but back before the Amazing
Spiderman started Sam Raimi was in talks
to direct spider-man for he was in talks
for a while and when those talks broke
down and he ultimately decided not to
make that with Sony almost immediately
Sony announced the amazing spider-man
reboot new new scripts we're getting a
director new acted like I felt like out
of nowhere but was very
you say has been building this behind
the scenes to just be able to take off
like a shot when and if Raimi decided to
bail and I feel like in a lot of ways
they've been quietly baking this venom
thing behind the scenes in much the same
fashion for whatever reason they decided
to now glom onto this release date now
that Aquaman's off it now a better movie
in and of itself is a slightly it be
proposition for me I mean I I like venom
I went when I was a kid I loved venom
but I'm not a kid anymore if he's still
a popular character I actually don't
really have a good gauge on that I mean
he's still around but like a lot of
long-lived characters with close ties to
popular ones
kind of gets a free ride there's a lot
of characters like that I don't know how
popular the guy would actually be
considered to be at this point so it
seems odd that Sony has really been
trying so hard to get him on screen for
a while well not on screen so much that
mean connected to spider my sure but as
a solo feature that still strikes me as
weird but all of this would just be kind
of okay that's just a little odd that
seems to be happening fast sort of thing
it wasn't for one big thing which is
that every indication right now is that
this will have zero to do with the not
only be MCU as a whole but even with
spider-man homecoming this is being
developed at a completely standalone
piece that will not connect to the MCU
at all so my immediate question is
what's the point
the reason venom is anything to anybody
is because of his connection to
spider-man and more to the point the
most popular version of venom which is
any Brock he is the best known and best
loved version of venom only works in
connection to spider-man on both levels
because there's two halves Debenham
you've got the alien suit you've got
whoever it's attached to and in the case
of Eddie Brock both of those things are
directly tied to spider-man in a way
that you can't really separate them
because what gravitates Eddie eeo in his
hatred and motivates him as a villain is
his hatred of
man the reason the suit Guam's on to him
in the first place instead of anybody
else is not only just that he was there
but the reason bonds with him and stinks
with him is their shared nature
spider-man the suit having been rejected
by spider-man after being his dude for a
while so again both halves of the
character in its most popular version
require spider-man what on earth makes
don't think anybody would care without a
spider-man connection that's not even me
saying you can't do a venom solo movie
you could do a venom solo movie I just
don't see how you could do it in a way
that anybody would give a damn about
unless you exceeded it with spider-man
somewhere along the line I mean I
understand there are alternate versions
of venom at this point a lot of
different people have had the suit you
know recently there was the whole agent
venom thing which I had a conversation
with Ryan Daly a month back where I kind
of floated the idea that maybe if they
were going to go venom solo that would
be the way they have to do it because
that seemed more detached from
spider-man specifically but even if
you're who spread image from the origin
the connection to the spider-man is a
big part of the iconic look of the suit
I mean look the symbol the big white
spidery thing in the middle the reason
that there and because it has a relation
to spider-man let's reason it looks like
that if you have no connection to
spider-man or spider-man it doesn't even
appear to exist in the universe of this
standalone movie why would it look like
that and if you designed to look like
anything else it's not venom so what
what why what is it I'm sure there are
some people out there wondering how is
Marvel allowing them to do this they're
not Marvel doesn't have say over this is
so bad so far as we understand the
agreement that Marvel and Sony reached
was for shared custody of spider-man and
for Marvel to help oversee and guide
spider-man solo films all the other
spider-man affiliated characters that
Sony has the rights to make movies up
they're under no obligation to consult
with Marvel at all so as long as they
disconnect it from the MCU they can do
whatever they want with venom the
sinister six they could still make that
Aunt May being a spy in the sixties
movie if they really wanted to do it and
they wouldn't need Marvel's approval
they wouldn't need Marvel say-so
that said if they
oh this way I have to wonder if that's
gonna sour the relationship between Sony
and Marvel I really have to wonder right
now there's a lot of angry or harsh
phone calls being made between
executives going what the hell are you
doing between Marvel and Sony and again
Sony's completely within their rights to
do this they have the print likeness I
just don't understand what I would I
mean knew that do they not understand
that the reason anyone is excited about
spider-man anymore is because of the
they're linking to the MCU and what they
were able to build with Tom Holland with
the help of Marvel that's the only
reason anyone is still interested in the
new spider-man movie coming out because
people were kind of done with amazing
spider-man after that second one so why
were they immediately relaunch into this
thing that nobody seemed excited for the
only thing I can think it was this is a
move of desperation because Sony is not
in a great place in terms of getting
stable tentpoles going because amazing
you know spider-man with spider-man solo
movies they have to share at the very
least they're sharing custody and some
degree of creative control with Marvel
whether or not there's proper sharing
involved in that I don't know I don't
think that was made public but
regardless they've got to share the toy
somewhat if they want something
completely under their control they
haven't been having a great run of luck
then ghostbusters laughter that was
their bid for the next big franchise it
didn't take off so I think maybe what
happened is the executives and suddenly
just got fancy they were sitting on
these things like oh we've had all these
plans and we can do it nothing because
we can't let's just do it what common
sense says you can and I'm just kind of
just for a quick second acknowledge it
has been suggested and if this were the
case it would be kind of cool of course
now if it is the case it's you know been
spoiled by speculation but there's a
movie coming out that is a Sony movie
called life and if you've seen the
trailers it's like this little tiny bit
of light discovered on Mars takes over
this satellite it's like it's growing
rain we haven't gotten a good look of it
beyond like you know it's this little
thing it's somehow growing and spreading
but it was suggested that this might be
a secret
venom origin movie and honestly that's
it kind of cool I doubt it I would be
shocked if it is but I'll tell you what
I bet you right now
there
whole bunch of Sony executives going
crap we should have thought of that but
a venom movie in 17 months coming out
does anybody think this is a good idea
does anyone think this is going to be
anything other than really painful
whatever your thoughts are on the whole
situation drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter I council of geeks give a listen
to the Cal CDs podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]